all right new game against a total fish
cake whatever this means is there a fish
cake don't think so ok so one let's play
this the McCutcheon variation always
interesting ok and I really don't know
the theory I only know a bit of this
should be too and I don't and I have
absolutely no idea about this this line
ok hmm
Jim
arcam Queen 85 he can even play c3m I
take it we should be to ya then this was
probably a very easy otic way to play
with the one taking ya f3 is a serious
serious move can i play f3 Queen 85 c 3
night XD for ya ok we are probably
finding out soon ok he's just preparing
this but I can of course them play the
Sun was with this also 94 so the threat
now
ok that's the CIT covers canvas but on
f3 I can still take so maybe b6 Bishop
Asaph f3r I just hope that 94 is working
takes on e4 I plane at c2 to a 1 I mean
just grabbing stuff and I'm threatening
Bishop a six now putting pressure on the
on the night so Bishop a 6mm and then f3
yeah right you fibers know who Bishop e2
he can take me for but it's not so this
terrible probably probably it is
Bishop a6f three yeah I cannot go to g5
there should be two fe foil maybe I can
take rook takes yeah okay I don't see I
don't see an alternative really
or maybe still 95 it looks completely
ridiculous but
we should be tulips terrible maybe in
comparison this is better I don't think
you can take him okay you see
threatening see form problem it okay
let's go here if it takes on age 6
nothing I can do I just need to need to
continue and hope for the best
yeah i'm not sure but i couldn't really
take on e 2 + f1 this was this was
really terrible I mean this is not
exactly great but yeah what Queen g7
deserve is either winning or or really
weird what what is your idea just want
to attack the pawn yeah not sure
the office is basically trapping its own
Queen so this is why I'm not
understanding the the moose Bishop g5
play rook g8 and win the porn I win the
peace the only thing is I'm not probably
not threatening much maybe Luke g8 takes
Knight d8 but it's got Queenie 70
Queenie sound one more
hmm
federal night is a blur threaten I
threaten night a fav come on I need to
need to play quick am
maybe he just plays g-form
hmm
just covering the denied hi Roxy 123
rogue f3 it's just working for white
Queen 86 even those moves are probably
sufficient maybe I can take come on
let's try this we should take that I've
got Quincy 3m maybe this this is
irritating
maybe
Luke see more
yeah this is a check and I'm threatening
here okay need to take with us and I've
got an extra piece out of nothing
admittedly not really deserved
yeah this is a very good night covering
b6 covering everything
yeah cool King be 50 yeah trying to trap
it
time joining
check yep
that should be the end of the game you
have this was lucky check check check
check okay disconnected yeah this was
not really deserved yeah I got into big
trouble out of this opening I mean it's
it's a very sharp opening and if you you
don't know what you're doing yo your you
need to solve it all on the board at
least the computer doesn't give wider
winning advantage okay b6 computer likes
it funny okay Bishop a6 also and here
the computer gives / should be too even
though yeah I wasn't completely sure but
it looked to the system this is bad Dino
yeah I was afraid about this look at
this year Brooke and now I thought here
this this pressure this pressure okay
and I thought yeah but what I didn't
really appreciate after by my capture
here he cannot take of course cannot
take and he cannot so easily switch on
the F file I mean she's rehang it's all
with check and um you have to have Queen
d5 coming yeah this is ok I mean the
computer gives it as equal and the sum
is a good sign if it doesn't loose
immediately then practice black is
probably probably all right now I don't
I don't like it still but in the game it
seemed much worse than it now appears to
be
when this this is this is soon yeah this
is just bad then but he he lost the
threat and somehow I mean I didn't
really understand why he put the Queen
on g7 it's just putting it in danger but
ok it's may be alright this this is lost
I mean it's clear but ok look see one is
winning now yeah yeah this is what I saw
I actually look see one Queen d3 rookery
but he took this surprised me ok now
here and now not g5 is actually equal
according to the computer why
interesting not because of this because
of taking yeah it was just a gamble
anyway I didn't have any big alternative
ok the computer gives them gives this as
a perpetual ok like this this ends and
I'm and now and then check virtual check
but what did he do he played the looks
you want I know this genders just just
drops the piece yeah maybe he was so
hypnotized by the time that he didn't
really pay so much attention I don't
know yeah thanks for watching